HBO's fantasy epic "Game of Thrones" had very
few happy endings to offer, killing beloved
characters left and right and upsetting fans
in the process — allegedly, George R.R.
Martin approved those character arcs, or at
the least didn’t overrule them, but still,
fans didn’t get the ending they wanted.
You can have your least favorite character
ending, but certainly if you say that one
of the worst endings actually went to Daenerys
Targaryen right at the end of the show, you’d
be hard pressed to find disagreement.
Played by English actress Emilia Clarke, the
icy-haired, dragon-riding daughter of the
Mad King Aerys II Targaryen had one of the
most epic character turns in TV history.
Early on, Dany appeared to be the ultimate
Big Good for the show: She's headstrong, liberates
cities and takes care of others, faces hardships
and comes out of them stronger than before.
At the time, she also seemed to have the most
legitimate claim to rule the Seven Kingdoms.
But in the penultimate episode of Game of
Thrones and its controversial finale, Daenerys
does a full 180.
She and her followers — including her nephew-slash-lover
Jon Snow — storm King's Landing, where Dany
uses her fire-breathing dragon to kill thousands
and destroy everything in her path.
Daenerys' series-long protagonist arc ends
in a hard-heel turn — and, ultimately, in
death, courtesy Jon Snow.
On one hand, having one of your most powerful
and beloved characters abruptly descend into
madness and break bad is par for the course
for "Game of Thrones."
Nevertheless, many fans feel that the arc
was badly handled, and Daenerys' ultimate
fate was simply one of the things that went
wrong with "Game of Thrones."
As such, it's interesting to hear just what
Clarke herself thinks of the character's ultimate
fate — and, as it happens, she recently
shared some of her views on the subject.
During an appearance on MTV News correspondent
Josh Horowitz's podcast, Happy Sad Confused,
Emilia Clarke shared her views on the subject
of the "Game of Thrones" finale.
It looks like she fully understands the criticism,
but noted that her job as an actor requires
her to be "on the same page" with the series'
creators and writers — regardless of how
she might feel.
"I get why people were pissed.
I totally get it."
She then opened up about her personal point
of view, noting that she'd portrayed Daenerys
for eight seasons, so she was committed to
play her well until the very end.
Clarke said,
"Me being the actor, you can't do justice
to the character that you've poured your blood,
sweat, and tears into for a decade without
getting on the same page [with the creative
decisions the team has made].
So, like, I'm not going to be there being,
like, 'Pfft!
Fine, I'll do the scene, whatever.'
You have to turn up.
Because why?
Because you're doing it for you, and you're
doing it for her, and you're doing it for
the show, and you're doing it for the storytelling."
Clarke added that while she does "have a certain
autonomy over what flavor" she can bring to
the story she's tasked with telling, but the
end product is ultimately out of her hands.
"The editor decides what it looks like, and
the writer decides what I'm saying.
So you just gotta go in and try and give it
as much truth and honesty ... and yourself
as you possibly can."
When Horowitz asked whether Clarke had suspicions
that people would be upset over "Game of Thrones"
finale when she first saw the Season 8 scripts,
the actress said,
"Well, the first instinct when you read the
scripts is you just get that gut punch of
like, 'Whoa, okay!'
You're thinking about — your first reaction
is that.
It's 'okay.'
And then you start to go, 'Oh.
Maybe people are going to ... mmm, yeah.'"
Clarke then admitted that she "wondered" whether
people might enjoy the events of the series
finale, and revealed that she hadn't looked
at any reviews for the show for the entire
time she was on it, nor any fan receptions
for plot points, so she wasn't about to start
after the finale aired.
“YOU’RE A BIT LATE FOR THAT!”
Regardless, Clarke did take a very diplomatic
approach to the situation.
One can certainly try to read between the
lines on her meaning,
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about disappointing
TV show endings coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.